Donald Trump is demanding reinstatement
and suggesting the government be
overthrown this is what happens when you
try to lead an Insurrection it fails and
you suffer no real consequences what do
you expect to see happen
Newsweek reports
Donald Trump demands reinstatement
suggests overthrowing government
this all uh happened of course on Donald
Trump's uh platform truth social which I
know you're familiar with I won't even
bother playing the clip in the midst of
a crucial week for the former president
over his role in January 6 Capital
attack and his tax returns Trump doubled
down on his big lie the debunked
conspiracy that the 2020 presidential
election was stolen Trump posting to
truth social quote the FBI and Twitter
colluded to elect Joe Biden now that's a
lie
Jesse Waters quoting Jesse Waters in
other words the 2020 presidential
election was rigged it was not and
stolen
it was not Trump says it all began a
long time ago they spied on my campaign
they did not I will remind you the claim
about spying on my campaign is the
following
during the 2016 presidential campaign
Trump and people around him were in
touch with so many targets of law
enforcement investigations who were
under surveillance that when the Trump
people would get on the phone with the
targets of law enforcement they would be
surveilled incidentally because they
were in touch with so many suspicious
people Trump's campaign was not being
spied on Trump's campaign was so sketchy
and it was in touch with so many uh uh
believed to be criminals that they were
incidentally surveilled okay let's go
back to the truth here uh spite on my
campaign not true and tried to rig the
2016 election but failed that is a lie
remember our government is doing this
not a person or party what should be
done about such a terrible thing or
should we let someone who was elected by
cheating and fraud stay in office and
continue to destroy our country
understand what he's saying there
he's saying based on his
misunderstanding and lies about what
happened
Joe Biden shouldn't be allowed to stay
in office now there is no constitutional
or legal basis for that so all that is
left is exactly the type of violent
government overthrow and coup that
Donald Trump attempted to pull off in
2020 but thankfully failed and one of
the things that I hope we have learned
at this point is that the the argument
over he's deluded or he believes it he's
joking or he's positioning and it's a
grift and it's Financial or whatever it
doesn't matter in the end what we
believe about the individual that is
making the claims what matters is what
do their followers ultimately believe
and what we learned in January of 2021
is that the followers believed it enough
that hundreds of them nearly a thousand
maybe the real number is over a thousand
and we just don't have the full number
yet 700 or so
uh committed specific crimes for the
allegedly committed specific crimes for
which they're being charged and many
have already been adjudicated and
thousands and thousands more were
willing to add this add themselves to a
mob uh that was filled with hundreds of
specific lawbreakers so whether Trump
believed it or he didn't or he wanted to
instigate or he wanted to use it as a
tool to raise money it really doesn't
matter it's sort of like yesterday we
talked about oh Sean Hannity under oath
said he didn't believe any of Trump's
claims fine he didn't believe him so
it's actually almost worse knowingly he
repeated incorrect statements that fed
the machine that ultimately led to the
January 6 riots and I go back to what I
said at the beginning
if you're never held accountable
if you don't suffer any consequences why
on Earth would you change your behavior
so Trump is back talking again about the
removal of Biden the overthrow of the
government and the reinstatement of
himself now it's not going to happen the
way he could get himself reinstated is
by winning in November of 2024 and let's
hope that does not happen but unless
there are real consequences for these
people and maybe we will soon know
whether there will be for Trump
why would they ever stop doing the same
stuff over and over again they wouldn't
and so we're uh fomenting this very
thing happening again via that lack of
consequences scary and disgusting stuff
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
holdon bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below